foreign
comes from Brook in Texas we are newly
married and just completed baby step one
I just graduated from college and do not
have a job but start my new job next
month making 16 an hour full time my
husband is currently in the military and
is getting released but we don't know
when he is getting honorably discharged
my question to you is this should we
start working on baby step two or should
we work on saving our three to six month
emergency fund all right Brooke here's
what I'm thinking
so we know that we have a possible I'm
not going to call it a job loss but a
job shift coming up and what I don't
want you guys to do is wait
until you you know I don't want you to
wait until he's discharged and then have
him looking for a job I want you guys to
start putting out feelers now so that we
can start to kind of close that Gap and
the way I would approach this is I would
start stacking up money as though you
were going to put it onto your debt
snowball but I would kind of set it
aside and and once this once this this
Smoke Clears of these job transitions
then I want you putting that money onto
baby step two I don't want you to keep
it there I don't want you to do the baby
steps out of order it's not going to be
your three to six months emergency fund
it's just going to be money stacked up
in case you do have that job loss and
then I want you to put it to baby step
two When the Smoke Clears what do you
think Dave that's fine
[Music]
um
traditionally Brooke we see too often
folks transitioning out of the military
wait until they're out of the military
to start their job look that's a mistake
you need to go ahead and very carefully
Target he needs to go ahead and very
carefully Target what his next season of
life looks like what his next career is
going to be get in the king Coleman
materials take the get clear assessment
on Ken's stuff get the proximity
principle book paycheck to purpose book
start looking at the resume templates
and all that and then go go ahead and
start looking for and Landing the new
job it's not unusual he has a pretty
good idea
when he's going to be cut loose I mean
within a month or two yeah and so and as
you get closer and closer it's going to
get dialed in more and more and more and
you can dial in the job
um maybe you're just practicing a little
bit early but go ahead and practice go
ahead and go out go out there and do the
interviews get the job talk about you
know I'm not exactly sure when I'm going
to be released but when I am released
this is where I want to be and if they
need you to start this week well you
can't start this week I'm not eligible
for that position but
he needs to go get the next job lined up
and I'm a little confused how you
graduate from college and you make 16
dollars I'm wondering you can make 18
stocking shelves at Target
yeah
what in the world she needs to get her
income up yeah you're you're a step away
from Wendy's right there and I think
that I think you're a stuck behind
Wendy's yeah your step away but it's
behind yeah that's true oh man I don't
know what yeah I'm not sure what your
degree is in or what your career field
is but you've got some work to do on
your income absolutely but but trade is
Right temporarily we're in the middle of
a bunch of transition a bunch of storms
let's just pile up cash a big old pile
like you were like you were paying
aggressively on debt that's aggressively
pile the cash and then the day that he
lands the new position or the day that
the uncertainty around all of this goes
away
uh then you take that money you throw it
at your debt snowball down to one
thousand dollars and you start working
your baby steps straight up you're
exactly right that's right exactly how I
would approach this